only on CBS this morning we have the
results from an investigation of how the
Food and Drug Administration protects
the public with food recalls government
investigators looked at 30 voluntary
food recalls reported to the FDA between
October 2012 and May 2015
they found the recall process did not
always ensure the safety of the nation's
food supply
Anna warner spoke to one of the
investigators and she joins us now Anna
good morning good morning Dana you might
assume that if a food could make you
sick or even kill you it would be pulled
immediately from store shelves but
investigators from the Department of
Health and Human Services Office of
Inspector General found that hasn't
always been the case
they say if recalls don't happen
consumers can be put in jeopardy I think
anytime you have a situation where
people's lives are at risk I don't know
how lightly you could take that
investigator George neder and his team
reviewed 30 voluntary recalls out of
1500 overseen by the FDA over a two and
a half year period and found
deficiencies among them that the FDA
could not always ensure that firms
initiated food recalls promptly
something netter says can be a critical
failure 23 of the 30 recalls we looked
at what class one by definition can
cause a serious irreversible medical
condition or potentially can cause death
for example in a salmonella outbreak in
2014 linked to nut butter
investigators found it took 165 days
from the date the problem product was
identified to the date of the firm's
voluntary recall there were 14 illnesses
in 11 states during a listeria outbreak
later that same year linked to cheese
products auditors determined a series of
recalls took 81 days to complete at
least nine people became ill including
an infant who died and two pregnant
women lost their fetuses the company
owner later pled guilty to a felony we
have to be planned and we have to
prepare for the worst-case scenario and
that's why it's important for FDA to
drive the boat and always put themselves
in a position where they can use their
authorities and enforce these recalls
when necessary
in another case a class one recall
of an adulterated dietary supplement
when the FDA in the firm disagreed over
whether the product was lawful
investigators found the firm did not
recall the product until 303 days after
receiving a warning letter from FDA
three places for that one recall that
stuff was still on the Shelf when they
went out there three hundred three days
later that meant people could have been
buying it up to that three hundred and
three days so this product potentially
jeopardized lives and they left it on
shelves for close to a year that would
be correct the inspector general's
office first issued an alert on their
findings in 2016 the FDA responded by
putting a special team in place to
handle challenging high-risk recalls but
for this report FDA also said the 30
cases selected were extreme outliers and
claimed in the highest risk recalls
recall initiation took place on average
in less than three days in a statement
to CBS News FDA Commissioner Scott
Gottlieb said the agency has worked
quickly to put in place measures to
address the proposals the OIG outlined
and though we said a lot has changed
since then I know that much work remains
to be done if we're going to provide the
highest assurance of safety net IRS's
lives depend on it every day that a
recall is not initiated every single day
that goes by a person could potentially
get seriously ill or die from eating the
product on background FDA officials say
they know there are some things to work
on here in that statement the
commissioner said the agency is going to
announce some new measures this coming
year not only in regard to the recall
process itself but ways to get more
information out to the public more
quickly and one quick example for
example for parents a lot of parents can
relate to this is what if allergens
sneaked into a food like allergens like
nuts question is how do you get that
word out to the public more quickly so
that you're not just analyzing what the
danger is or taking a look seen where
it's coming from which batches hey you
need to get the word out so parents know
hey watch out for that product
that you in your report its these
recalls are voluntary done by the
companies they're not right they're
mandated by the FDA
they're voluntary sort of in cooperation
with the FDA and I'll have phone
conversations you know with the company
the company typically any good company
wants to get a product off the shelf
because it's going to hurt them in their
reputation and of course I think that
most of them they don't want to hurt
people you know it's a question of how
do you make that process work how long
has it been that company a has been
talking about recalling a product yeah
it's important reporting great reporting
Anna thank you and I thank you very much